Kamali we were in Philadelphia
Philadelphia back in February February
February where we saw such similar
scenes to that that you've just seen in
Martha kellner's report fentanyl
sometimes cut with things even more
deadly that are now emerging is it is in
cities right across this country but we
had heard that it was well beyond that
it was in small towns like this a
beautiful small town in southern Texas
not the place you would expect to find
such a deadly drug but it is here it is
in schools it is in homes and it is
devastating societies like this
we'd arrange to meet Stephanie and her
family at a park in Austin
then she said she'd bring some others
too
because fentanyl has broken so many here
we lost our son Tucker Rowe my
granddaughter Victoria Joanne I lost my
son Stephen James on February 17th of
this year she was 16 years old 17 years
old make no assumptions about this drug
there is no typical victim it is a
poison and it is killing Young Americans
up and down this country and she took
maybe what she thought was a Xanax to a
pill she was trying to use to relieve
her anxiety and sleep that was
unfortunately laced with fentanyl we
found her the next day we were
what is it 20 feet down the hall asleep
while she passed away and we had no idea
you can take your pick of devastated
communities here
just to the south of Austin is the town
of Kyle
and we're out with the local police
chief this started less than 18 months
ago and when it did start it it came
with a vengeance
and it struck multiple families just in
a matter of months sometimes a matter of
weeks we're a couple of hours here from
America's Southern border what is in
Mexico now
in a few short hours can be in the hands
of our residents here in this part of
the state in schools like that in
schools like that
last week a child overdosed in this
classroom It Is tragically telling that
they knew what to do so when we get
called we get called to a classroom
usually you can tell there's a sense of
urgency over our radios when we're
listening so when we get there we look
at the students sometimes they're blue
they're not responsive by any means they
have a the death snore it's really scary
to hear
um we just give the Narcan as quick as
possible get them on the ground and make
sure there's a pulse if not we have to
initiate CPR
sometimes or if there is a pulse we can
kind of resuscitate them back with
rescue breeding goodness and is that
student okay as far as I know yes
the young girl survived thanks to this a
reversal treatment Narcan they keep it
on hand
but often it's not enough in this school
district they have lost five students
since last summer children
it could be anybody close to you it
could be anybody around you and it just
hurts
knowing that it could be you
you know covet and the depression the
anxiety that children faced and that
people are still living with today and
not combined with this
relatively easy to get and lethal drug
is really what's causing it to be so
hard on our community
Jerry skrocky is the school district
security director I think we're being
successful on that first time user I
think that that we're that they're
getting the message and I think that
parents and those kids are eating us
where I think we are not reaching is
those kids who already are addicted and
I think that goes back hand in hand to
the the lack of resources and the lack
of mental health treatment absolutely
but you can feel the heaviness here a
burden beyond anything they should face
nobody wants to be working in overdose
on anyone but let alone a child
um and and it happening in the middle of
a school day
um it's just
sorry
it's rough yeah it really is
this stuff is a game changer because
you're dealing with uh sometimes 14 15
16 year old kids that are dying from
just one one blue pill Sergeant Tommy
Villanueva leads the drug busts in the
community he doesn't want to be
identified but he can reveal what
they've seized
these are the pills that the kids are
taking those are the most popular ones
that we're seeing yes sometimes they're
cutting them in half and or a quarter or
just taking a sliver correct would you
feel Tommy that this is a this is a
battle you're winning are you are you
getting on top of this or are you up
against it no sir we're up against it
they're we're not winning it at all
we're managing what we do have and what
we do find and the information we do get
um
but no we're not winning this is just a
small fraction of what is here what
we've seen what we've seized
back in Austin in the park Dusk and they
were still telling us their stories but
it's the drug the drug is so addictive
and is so powerful and it steals lives
and that's what it did to our son
[Music]
he was a great big brother and um
he was just always there
they are bound by grief and a drug
that's killing Americans in record
numbers
we're going to continue to fight and
honor his name he will not be just
another statistic not as long as I'm
living
all right and I am afraid to tell you
that we've just had a tragic update from
the school that you saw in that report
there they have confirmed that another
child a 15 year old girl has died from
an overdose a young girl who would have
thought that she was taking a painkiller
or a sleeping pill or was just
experimenting like kids do and she died